the U.S has condemned what it called a
reckless maneuver by a Russian jet which
has brought down an American drone the
fighter jet collided with the propeller
of the Drone as it was flying over the
Black Sea south of Ukraine the U.S
military says the unmanned drone was
over international waters and posed no
threat let's bring in our correspondent
shihad ratanzi he's joining us live from
Washington D.C it's a very uh strongly
worded statement from the U.S government
as you would expect she had what more do
we know about the incident what more are
they saying
well the interest of the code at 7am
local time so 6 a.m
GMT in fact two Russian fighter jets had
been shadowing this Reaper drone which
the U.S says was over international
waters a spy drone clearly an area of
sensitivity to the Russians that the
Russians clearly feel that you know with
the black seed the vicinity of Crimea
this is their sphere of influence it's
actually pretty common I think that we
we have that kind of shadowing between
adversarial fighter jets and an aircraft
and drones in this area and in other
regions around the world what's
different of course is this Collision
but I will read that just a little bit
from the statement from U.S European
command and all we have right now is
confirmation from the U.S it has to be
said we haven't heard from the Russians
but it does does sped out quite a
detailed narrative it says one of the
Russian su-27 aircraft struck the
propeller of the MQ-9 the Drone
um causing U.S forces to have to bring
the MQ-9 down on an international waters
several times before the Collision the
su-27s dumped fuel on and flew in front
of the MQ-9 in a reckless
environmentally unsound and
unprofessional manner the incident
demonstrates a lack of competence in
addition to being unsafe and
unprofessional that's quite interesting
that sort of that stressing of a lack of
competence which suggests perhaps that
the the US may think it was all it may
have been an accident may have been
unintended at least the Collision the
Collision itself but then the statement
does go on to warn the Russians about
aggressive actions that are dangerous
and could lead to miscalculation and
unintended escalation which I think is
why we're all concerned about about
incidents like that but we do have to
put it into that context of of this sort
of shadowing be rather being rather
routine but but not so much the the
actual Collision itself and so how
significant would you say the incident
is she have given the context of the um
the relations between us and Russia
right now now
well I mean this is why against national
news organizations are leading with it
because clearly there's a great deal of
tension between the US and Russia but
then again I think it's very important
to keep this into the context of of the
sort of interactions uh and engagement
that we see on a pretty routine basis
between the air the air forces and the
drones of of adversarial countries like
the US and Russia we know that Joe Biden
was briefed earlier this morning the
state department says it will be
expressing its concerns to Russian
officials there's a pentagon briefing
that was already scheduled which is
going to be happening in the next half
an hour or so so perhaps we'll learn a
little bit more about what how the US is
viewing this and also about the recovery
efforts for the Drone still nothing
though from from the Russians I think
that'll be rather interesting because
because you have to remember because
these these Reaper drones are quite
substantial themselves it'd be
interesting to know what sort of damage
this may have done to the to the Russian
aircraft as well
joining us live with the latest from
Washington DC thank you Shia